Okay, welcome back. Welcome to video
number nine. In video number eight, we got
perspective by looking at and defining
what type of market we're actually in,
whether it was a bull or a bear market, as
defined by the professional trader
definition.
Now we're going to move on to get more
perspective. We're going to try and get
perspective on what drives global stock
market returns. And what really drives
global stock market returns is a country's
income, gross domestic product. And we're
going to look at what gross domestic
product is and get historical perspective
of gross
gross domestic product, GDP, relative to
major stock markets and stock market
returns around the world. And we're going
to look at gross domestic product
primarily in the United States. You're
going to see when we go to the
presentation why this is so important.
We're going to look at the presentation
why this is so important. And we're going
to look at what we're going to look at.
And we're going to see when we do this,
the odds of making money, if we follow and
are able to predict GDP using the stock
market as a proxy for that prediction,
you're going to see that the odds are
going to be now stacked massively in our
favour.
We're also going to compare US gross
domestic product versus the Eurozone in
its entirety and also Chinese GDP. Now,
when you add up all of these regions
together, you actually get to 50% of the
world's total income.
And if we add up all of these regions
together and if we can find a way of
predicting the United States gross
domestic product, the Eurozone gross
domestic product and Chinese gross
domestic product, we're going to have a
very, very good idea of global stock
market returns in the future.
And this is what we move on to next after
we've gone through defining why GDP is so
important and looking at the reasons why
it's so important.
And now we're going to go over to the
stage and I want you to really focus on
the size of the United States and why
predicting US GDP becomes one of the most
important things for a professional
trader.
Once you've got this understanding of the
relative size of the United States and the
Eurozone and Chinese GDP versus the rest
of the world, you're really going to
understand what drives stock market
returns and then we're going to move on to
the next point where we're going to try
and start predicting US GDP, Eurozone GDP
and Chinese GDP using indicators that
predict the future.
Okay, let's go over to the presentation
and I'll see you for a summary after the
presentation.
In a top-down systematic process, the
first thing we do is we look at GDP, gross
domestic product.
First thing we're going to look at is why
it's so important.
Once you realise the importance of certain
parameters of global GDP, you'll start
appreciating really why markets move the
way they do.
And this sits right at the top.
This is our world view.
Is GDP going to grow?
Is GDP going to contract?
Is it going to grow in the US, contract in
Europe, grow in China?
These are the views that you've got to
have.
Those views that you've got to have.
Those views are going to dictate your
direction in your product.
So, you're going to look at what you're
going to look at.
If you're going to look at GDP, you're
going to look at what you're going to look
at.
If you think GDP is going to contract,
you're going to look at what you're going
to look at.
If you think GDP is going to contract,
you're going to look at what you're going
to look at.
If you think GDP is going to contract,
you're going to look at what you're going
to look at.
If you think GDP is going to contract,
you're going to look at what you're going
to look at.
If you think GDP is going to look at what
you're going to look at.
Is GDP going to grow?
Is GDP going to contract?
Is it going to grow in the US?
Contract in Europe?
Grow in China?
These are the views that you've got to
have.
Those views are going to dictate your
direction in your portfolio across all
asset classes.
If you think GDP is going to contract and
you're very, very long at everything.
Your book represents, your trading account
represents the total opposite of what you
believe.
So you've got stupid positions.
Your book has to be an absolute perfect
representation of what you think is going
to happen in the future.
So let's get some definitions straight.
Nominal GDP, total income of a country for
a given year.
Real GDP, adjusted for inflation, adjusted
for prices.
Recession, two consecutive quarters of
negative real GDP.
When you see a guy on TV, an economist,
talking about GDP, they mean real GDP.
So they use the term loosely GDP, but what
it means is real GDP.
We know what correlation is.
I'm not going to tell you what that is.
You should know.
Leading indicators, indicators that move
before the economy as a whole.
Lagging indicators, indicators that move
after the economy as a whole.
So what are we interested in?
We're interested in leading indicators
that do what?
Conduct the movement of the economy.
So what's the economy?
Real GDP.
You can have an appreciation of nominal,
but what really matters is real GDP.
Real GDP.
And this is the causality profile of
essentially the stock market.
Real GDP, and I'm just going to refer to
it now as GDP.
Just assume that it's real GDP.
Real GDP, growth, leads to growth in
earnings of companies.
Lead to the value of the S&P 500 to go up.
However, the S&P 500 is a leading
indicator in itself.
And predicts the future rise and fall of
GDP.
And therefore, earnings.
So by the time a company reports, the
market's already moved.
And by the time GDP is reported, the
GDP is reported every quarter and it's
backwards looking.
It tells you what happened in the last
three months.
The market tells you what's going to
happen in the future.
Why?
Because everyone trading that market and
using it as an expression of their view in
the world
is trying to predict the future and using
leading indicators to do it.
So by default, the market becomes a
leading indicator itself.
Make sense?
What we're going to look at now is a crude
correlation of S&P 500 and GDP.
Going back to 1950.
So you guys can spend lots of money on
degrees.
Tens of thousands of pounds.
Learn how to do correlations.
But if you just stick two variables in a
spreadsheet and give them a zero or a one.
If they move together or they don't in a
given time horizon, you'll still get
literally the same answer.
So the market trades every day.
But GDP is reported every quarter.
Q1 GDP, so January, February, March, is
reported at the end of April.
Q2 GDP is reported at the end of July.
Q3 GDP is reported at the end of October.
And Q4, full year GDP, is reported at the
end of January for the previous year.
But the market trades every day.
So if they move in the same direction, we
can use the S&P 500 to predict GDP.
And just buy it and sell it now.
Does that make sense?
If you've got two variables, there's only
four things that can happen.
They either both go down.
They both go up.
One goes down, one goes up.
Or one goes down, one goes up, one goes
down.
There's only four things that can happen
over a time period.
So what you do here, you take the GDP
numbers every quarter that are reported
one month after the quarter.
You time lag it.
So you put it in as the month.
So Q1 is April here.
And you take the S&P 500 on a monthly
basis.
So for every one number GDP is reported,
there'll be three closing prices for the
month of S&P.
And then you say whether the S&P was up or
down in the period before GDP was
reported.
Make sense?
So let's start here with this one.
At the end of Q1, 1950, the GDP of the
United States was 1.696.8 trillion.
Okay?
That's trillion dollars.
Anyone know what the GDP of the U.S. will
be this year?
And what about last year?
Who said 15?
It's 15, 16 trillion.
So you can see how much GDP has grown in
the U.S. since 1950.
The S&P 500.
The S&P 500 in April was 17.53.
April 1950.
Now the S&P 500.
The S&P 500.
Now the S&P 500 is at 15.40 now.
The S&P 500 is at 15.40 now.
The S&P 500.
And what about last year?
Who said 15?
It's 15, 16 trillion.
So you can see how much GDP has grown in
the U.S. since 1950.
The S&P 500 in April was 17.53.
April 1950.
The S&P 500 is at 15.40 now.
1,540.
So you'd have done pretty well if you
bought it at 17.5.
It's a big return.
But by the way, if you'd have day traded
it every day, you'd have lost money.
Second quarter, GDP went up.
So this is an annualised GDP number by the
way.
So every quarter you get the annualised
GDP for the U.S.
So it goes up from 1696.8 to 1747 spot 3.
So it's reported in that period as up.
What happened to the S&P 500?
It went from 1753 to 1877, sorry, 1764.
So it was up.
So the S&P 500 was up in that month, in
that quarter, and GDP was up in that
quarter.
Yeah?
So what do we do?
Well, we give them a score in different
columns.
And we have four situations.
A 0-0 situation is when in a quarter the
S&P 500 goes down and then GDP is reported
down.
The 1-1 situation is in a quarter the S&P
500 goes up and GDP is reported up.
So what's a 0-1?
S&P 500 down, GDP up.
And then 1-0, S&P 500 up, GDP down.
What do we think the results are?
Someone have a guess.
Which one's got the most numbers in it?
1-1.
The market's gone up over 60 years.
Why has the market gone up?
Because GDP has gone from 1-6-9-6 trillion
to 15 and a half trillion.
Here's the results here.
60% of what?
60% of quarters.
So we've got a total of 245 quarters.
The S&P 500 goes up.
And then after that move, GDP is reported
as being positive versus the last quarter.
146 quarters out of 245.
19 are reported as S&P 500 moves down and
then GDP is reported down.
So they both move in the same direction
67% of times.
67% of quarters in the last 60 years.
What happens when it doesn't?
What happens when they move in the
opposite direction?
Well, the vast majority of times, the S&P
500 goes down and GDP is reported up when
it goes
wrong.
25% of times.
So why would that actually happen?
It's because the expectations in the stock
market of GDP are too high for that
current quarter.
So the market goes down on profit taking
and then GDP is actually reported up.
So expectations get ahead of themselves
and the market prices everything in too
much.
Make sense?
You can see only 7% of times since 1950,
S&P 500 has moved up and GDP has gone
down.
So you can pretty much say that's never
going to happen.
Very rarely.
So what's going to happen most of the
times, one or two things is going to
happen.
They're either going to move in the same
direction or when they don't, the
expectations in the market
have become too high.
That's it.
So historically, GDP explains 67% of S&P
500 moves on a quarterly basis.
What does that mean in terms of odds?
It means we've now got three to two odds
in our favour if we can predict it
accurately.
Better than 50-50 and better than day
trading.
This is why when you increase your time
horizon, you have a better chance of
making money over
the long term because you're starting to
stack the odds in your favour.
When it doesn't, the vast majority of
times it's because S&P 500 moves down, GDP
doesn't
go down, goes up and we get profit taking
or short term panic in the market.
That happens 25% of times so the odds of
that happening in a given year are 4 to 1
against.
Make sense?
So if there's four quarters in a year,
what should we expect once a year?
We can expect some profit taking in the
market where the expectations of the
markets become
too high and then GDP is reported after
but the S&P 500 goes down.
GDP is up but the S&P 500 has gone down in
that quarter.
We've got four quarters in a year.
Now what happens if we predict GDP
fundamentally and we manage to take
profits at the right time?
But if you do that, you're an absolute
superstar.
It basically means you're going to be
right 93% of the time in your life.
93% of quarters from now till the day you
retire.
But if you're getting that right, you'll
be retiring very young.
So mentally as professional traders, you
go in every year, objective to make money,
predict
GDP, one to three month time horizon, use
the stock market to represent my view.
And then when I think there's going to be
profit taking, I take profits and then GDP
is reported
and we start again.
It's literally that straight forward.
That's everybody's approach.
You're not going to be right 93% of
quarters in your life.
But if you can be right somewhere between
67 and 93, you can't fail to make money.
You just have to time your trades right.
Now this is only on indexes, commodities.
You also, because this is aggregate demand
in the economy.
So commodities are, most commodities are
cyclical.
So you can get, you get your commodities
views globally by predicting global and
regional GDP.
You get your currency views by doing that
as well.
And you get your rates views by doing that
Why?
Because rates policy responds to predicted
GDP.
What do we think all of the policy makers
around the world do when they set rates?
Do they wake up one morning and just
decide, we're going to put rates up today?
Because I had a funny dream last night.
Of course not.
They respond to real things that are
happening that are going to affect GDP in
the future.
So you can have views on rates.
What's a central bank going to do if
aggregate demand is collapsing?
They're going to smash rates lower.
You can have views on these things.
That's where you get them from.
So you get your views across asset
classes, stock market, indexes, indices,
cyclical commodities,
currencies, all your major currency pairs,
and rates.
You get all of those views from your view
on the world.
And there's multiple, multiple trades you
can do.
So if you don't want to even become a guy
or a trader that wants to trade anything
else except trade large-cap indices,
futures, commodities, currencies, and
rates.
You don't want to trade anything else
other than that.
So you don't want to trade stocks.
You don't want to trade options.
You don't want to trade sector ETFs.
You don't want to trade anything.
You don't want to go too deep.
That's your approach.
You can just literally have a world view
and trade these things based on your world
view.
And try to take profits at the right time.
So back to the perception of what a
professional trader does.
That's what they're obsessed with.
Professional traders and hedge fund
managers are obsessed with predicting GDP.
Let's have a look at some charts.
A picture fence a thousand words.
We like charts.
Traders love charts.
Okay.
Let's get some GDP appreciation for the
United States.
Nominal GDP from 1791 to 2011.
2007.
Goes positive.
Early 1950s.
Goes negative.
2008, 2009.
UK nominal GDP.
Positive from 1946 to 2009.
US real GDP.
Last four US recessions.
1973 to 1974.
80 to 82.
Double dip.
91.
And 2008 to 2009.
What was special about 2008 to 2009?
What was special about that recession?
Anyone know?
Remember what the definition of a
recession is?
What was it?
Negative one.
Two consecutive quarters.
Two consecutive quarters of negative real
GDP growth.
Why was the 2008 to 2009?
Two consecutive quarters of negative GDP
growth.
Why was the 2008 to 2009?
What was special about 2008 to 2009?
What was special about that recession?
Anyone know?
What was special about 2008 to 2009?
What was special about that recession?
Anyone know?
Remember what the definition of a
recession is?
What was it?
Negative one.
Two consecutive quarters.
Two consecutive quarters of negative real
GDP growth.
What was it?
Two consecutive quarters of negative real
GDP growth.
What was it?
Why was the 2008, 2009 one special?
It was more than before this.
Because we got four in a row.
So Q3 and Q4 08.
Q1 and Q2 09.
That hadn't happened for 70 years.
That's why it was special.
That's why rates are now at zero.
When we flick onto the next page,
we're going to look at the UK.
What do we think the UK looks like in
terms of the last four recessions?
What do you reckon?
Exactly the same.
You don't need to know anything about the
United Kingdom to trade the FTSE.
Because the UK GDP is just US GDP with a
K.
There they are overlaid.
Do you think the UK has any power in the
world whatsoever?
When you drive down Embankment and you
look at Parliament, what do you see?
What do you see?
What do you see when you look at
Parliament?
I see a submissive institution that's
subject to European law.
So they've got no power.
What do you do when you drive past the
Bank of England?
What do you see?
You might see a central bank.
I see a puppet of the Federal Reserve.
The last 200 years proves it.
If the US is growing, the UK will too.
If the US sneezes, the UK will catch a
cold and contract as well.
Literally anything you do as a trader, if
you trade on the back of UK statistics
that are backwards looking, you're an
idiot.
If you trade the FTSE based on UK retail
sales, you're the last person to the
party.
Because it was already predicted 12 months
ago.
And it wasn't predicted by looking at UK
statistics.
It was predicted by looking at US
Predicting US GDP.
So it seems that if you can predict US
GDP, you can also predict UK GDP.
You don't need to look at anything in the
UK.
It's irrelevant.
What's your view going to be on the Taiwan
index if US GDP is collapsing?
Sell Taiwan.
What's your view going to be on the Hang
Seng if US GDP is collapsing?
Sell Hang Seng.
Why is US GDP so important?
So here's the 2011 numbers.
So 2012 numbers are going to come out
soon.
Could be quite interesting.
So top 25 economies in the world.
US economy, two times bigger than China, a
little bit more.
If you add up the 24 countries outside of
the US, you get to 43 and a bit trillion.
US economy is still a third of that
number.
The US economy just drives global GDP.
Pretty much you can have, if you want,
everything if you can predict US GDP.
But we look collectively in Europe at the
Eurozone.
Because when you add up all of these
countries that have a common currency, the
Euro, you get to 13 trillion.
So we can have a view on the US economy.
So we can have a view on the Eurozone in
its entirety.
So it's 85% of the US economy.
If you add them both up, global GDP, 70
trillion.
The US is 22%.
The Eurozone is 18 and a half.
But we have to look at China as well.
Why?
Because it's growing at 8%.
And if you add them all up, you get to 50%
of the world's GDP.
And that table there basically says if
everything stays the same as it is now,
China will be the biggest economy in the
world in 2025.
So that's why we have to look at it.
The future of GDP and the future of global
stock markets will only be dependent on a
few things.
Whether the US can get itself out of its
mess and Chinese growth.
Because China is going to be the biggest
economy in 2025.
So this is how we get our world view.
Predicting GDP.
Historically, global GDP is driven by US
GDP.
It's the most important economy in the
world by far.
Just think of the US as a big obese
consumer.
And the whole world depends on the
consumption of that consumer.
If that consumer goes on a diet, the rest
of the world is screwed.
It drives global GDP and drives S&P 500
returns.
And S&P 500 returns are going to drive the
rest of the world as well.
So we've got to try and predict US GDP,
Eurozone and Chinese GDP.
That makes up half the world.
And we can have views on either or.
We can be bullish on the US, bearish on
China.
We can be bearish on the Eurozone, bullish
on China.
And then you have an overall view as well.
On the whole world.
So if those three economies are
contracting, global GDP will be lower.
And stock markets will go lower now before
they get reported as going down.
Because people will start selling six,
twelve months ahead of it actually
happening.
Because they'll be told by the leading
indicators that it's going to happen.
Okay, welcome back.
I hope you managed to get a good idea of
the numbers there.
And the numbers that we looked at really
were two-fold.
We looked at the size of the United
States.
The size of the US versus the rest of the
world.
The top 25 nations by gross domestic
product.
That was the first thing.
Second thing really that we looked at.
And this is the main thing.
Because the US is really so important in
terms of its gross domestic product.
And its size.
We took GDP and we had a look from 1960 to
the present day.
And we discovered that there's a very high
correlation.
Between the US gross domestic product.
And quarterly stock market returns.
Now, if we're going to be using the S&P
500 as a proxy.
For expressing our views on future levels
of GDP in the United States.
This is what we want to see.
We want to see that they both move in the
same direction.
And the conclusion that we got to was
actually over the last 50 or so years.
What's happened is that the S&P 500
manages to predict GDP.
And it does this two-thirds of the time.
So now when you compare this to day
trading for example.
When we looked at day trading in the first
part of the video series.
We're no longer looking at a situation
where things are 50-50.
where if we day traded the S&P 500 every
single day.
From 1960 to present day.
We would have lost money.
Now, if we'd have followed on a 1 month, 3
month time horizon.
And predicted GDP 3, 6, 9 and 12 months
out.
We would have actually made a hell of a
lot more money.
And this is what you have to do as a
professional trader.
US GDP is the most, by far, the most
important thing that you will ever
predict.
Because it tells you the direction that
you should be in your portfolio.
Not just in the United States.
But also probably for the rest of the
world.
And when we looked at those numbers.
We saw given the two-thirds correlation.
As in the S&P 500 predicts GDP.
And GDP moves in the same direction as the
S&P 500.
Two-thirds of the time.
Or two-thirds of quarters throughout
history.
When the S&P 500 is actually wrong in
predicting GDP.
It's usually wrong for a specific reason.
And that specific reason is actually
expectations of GDP growth become too
high.
So, what you have to try and do.
Coming into every single year as a
professional trader.
Is to try and predict GDP for at least
three quarters out of four.
Because we're not superheroes.
You know, every professional trader knows.
That they're going to get it wrong
sometimes.
So, we allow ourselves to get it wrong.
For at least one quarter a year.
Knowing that even if we get it wrong.
Two quarters a year.
We can actually still make money.
If we have good risk management.
So, if we come into each year.
And we try and get three quarters out of
four correct.
Then we're going to be right 75% of the
time.
And in each quarter.
We're actually always looking at least six
to 12 months ahead.
Trying to predict US GDP growth in the
future.
Now, predicting GDP growth in the United
States.
Can provide us with a good idea of long or
short or flat.
Or market neutral.
In our portfolio.
Not just in the United States.
But also globally.
But we have to be prudent.
We have to look at the Eurozone.
And Chinese GDP as well.
Because what you notice is the Eurozone.
Is pretty much the size of the United
States.
In its entirety.
But also China is growing at 8% per annum.
Which means by 2025.
China will actually be the size of the
United States.
So, China is becoming more and more
important.
Every single year.
So, when we predict GDP globally.
As professional traders.
We try to predict US GDP.
First of all.
Because that is the biggest and most
important.
Historically.
And at the moment.
We try to predict Eurozone GDP.
Because that is the common currency area.
That is the same size as the United
States.
Or just a little bit smaller.
And we try to predict Chinese GDP.
Because every year it becomes more and
more important.
Relative to both the US and the Eurozone.
So, we can also get an idea.
Not just of global direction.
In stock markets from US GDP.
We get global direction in stock markets.
From adding them all up.
And if we add them all up.
And find that Eurozone GDP growth cancels
out US GDP growth.
Or China cancels out both Eurozone and US.
Then our overall picture might look very
different.
And we may want to even look for
geographical exposure.
So, we can look at being long the US.
Short Europe.
Long China.
Long the United States.
So, we get a global perspective.
But we also get a regional perspective.
Now that you understand why GDP is so
important.
We have to learn now.
How to actually predict it.
So, what is there out there in the world
that predicts GDP 6-12 months in advance.
Or with a good time lag.
So, we can use global stock markets as our
proxy for predicting GDP.
And taking direction in our portfolio.
Well, we are going to move on to video
number 10 now.
And you are going to find out that what we
call these indicators are leading
indicators.
Because they lead GDP.
And they lead the stock market.
And the stock market itself is actually a
leading indicator.
Because it leads GDP.
So, let's go on to video number 10.
And in video number 10, we are going to
start with the biggest leading indicators
in the world.
You can always add more in if you want.
But you have to get the principle of
interpreting right.
Remember this principle that we spoke
about in the first section of the series.
The principle that we spoke about in terms
of professional traders' perspective.
And professional traders' approach was to
take the information that is relevant in
the world.
That 3% of information that is potentially
going to make you money.
And to cut out all of the noise.
Well, this is the information.
The information, 3% of information that is
relevant is really the importance of GDP.
And predicting GDP successfully.
And we do that with leading indicators.
But you have to interpret leading
indicators correctly.
And then turn it into real hard dollars.
Well, we are going to learn this in video
10 now.
We are going to start off by trying to
predict GDP with the biggest indicators in
the world.
The biggest leading indicators.
I will see you in video 10.
Tech.